you
every morning on every news flat I hear
the sorrow of the world it seems like
everybody's lost and scared trying to
make sense of it all and there's a trash
anomaly going please BTW you welcome to
the dean show which is a way of life
where we're trying to educate you the
audience about islam and muslims
directly from the source today's topic
will be islam in the Bible where I am
going to try to present to you the
audience that what Islam says now is the
same thing that has always been sent
throughout the Bible throughout all the
prophets of god throughout god from the
beginning of time until now and the
question i put out to you the audience
is no matter what your beliefs maybe
want to ask you where do you stand in
those beliefs do you stand in a position
in your beliefs where you can firmly say
that I know what I believe in I know its
sources I know they are authentic and I
can verify everything that I do within
my own beliefs directly from the sources
this I ask you today and i'm going to
show you and prove to you that I as a
Muslim and Islam can verify it sources
not only from our books from but from
the books of that God is always revealed
so God willing we're going to take a
journey through the bible and i'm going
to show you islam is in the Bible it is
the same message that has been taught by
all the prophets of God I begin by a
statement of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him where he said a very concise
statement and this is life eternal that
they may know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you have sent and this
is in John chapter 17 verse 3 this is
what he was saying and this is the way
to eternal life you would think that
this would have been a very good chance
had he been the son of God come to earth
to die questions this would have been a
very good chance for him to say the way
to eternal life is for you to accept me
as your Savior that I am going to die
for your sins and then my blood is your
means to salvation but he did not say
this what he said was that they may know
you the only one true God and Jesus
Christ whom
have sinned and that word sent means
sent as a messenger so this was the
statement of Jesus about how to attain
eternal salvation now if we look at some
of the descendants of Abraham which is
where all of the three major religions
the world can trace their lineage back
to its name traces its lineage back to
Abraham it's a Christian II can trace
his lineage back to Abraham islaamka
chase his lineage back to Abraham coming
from the sons of Abraham Isaac and
Ishmael we know that Isaac Moses
descended from Isaac and so came the
children of Israel the Jews and through
them came Jesus Christ now we know
Abraham also had a son named Ishmael and
we're going to discuss Ishmael and a
little more a little more in detail in
just a few minutes God with from Ishmael
descended the atoms and from the Arabs
directly came from a direct line from
Ishmael came the last prophet of God
Muhammad peace be upon him now as we
look today in the world we look at the
world population the world population
based on religion and based on Creed's
now we know that Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world it is
growing at an annual rate of two hundred
and thirty-five percent and it is said
that by the year 2015 according to
statistics that Muslims who are now
one-fourth of the world's population
will become half or over half of the
world's population Islam will be the
largest world religion so I ask you the
audience that a religion that is now the
fastest growing religion where
one-fourth of one out of every four
people in the world is Muslim why is it
that the majority and the masses of
people do not know the truth about Islam
they do not know what Muslims and that
which they do know is derogatory given
to them by various media outlets and
various sources that give derogatory
information as them why is it not that
people are searching to try to find out
the truth of islam for themselves based
on the fact that this way of life this
way of living will be the dominant way
of living we
in the next eight years God willing if
you were to go to school they will hit
you about everything they teach you
about how people migrated from Africa
through the the continental shelf
through the Antarctic shelf how the
Native Americans got here from after all
these small my new things they will
teach you but this way of life which
will be the most dominant way of life
God willing in the near future you know
nothing about you're taught nothing
about in this society and I want to know
and question people ask me why why don't
we know about Islam and Muslims why are
not more people speaking out on about
Islam and what really Islam says and
what Muslims are really about and I have
the question that you should ask the
same thing you should ask why are you
not being given this information why do
you not know about its name and why are
the only things that are given to you
about its length are negative this is a
question you yourself the audience must
ask those people around you now one of
the biggest misconceptions about Islam
is that it is an Arabic years of
religion founded by Arabs and practice
by Arabs which this is no way even close
to being the truth according to the
statistics only fifteen to eighteen
percent of the world Muslim population
or atoms the other eighty-two percent
are not Arabs so how can this be an Arab
religion when the Arabs are the minority
within the way of life well then what is
called the religion the religion of
Islam which is Islam as a way of life
not just a religion but for the use of
the common terminology we'll use the
word religion the religion of Islam not
Arabs make up the majority of the
population twenty percent African ten
percent come from Russia and China
seventeen percent come from Southeast
Asia thirty percent in the Indian Sun
captions 13 s % other places in the
world like Europe America South America
places like this ten percent Turkey Iran
Afghanistan US population is eighty-four
percent of those people who confess that
their religion is Christianity
three-point-seven percent Muslims which
is about 10 min which today is about 10
about 12 10 to 12 million people in this
country who are Muslims a very big
minority and
country muslim 2.1 percent jews 10.2
percent who say that they are other also
a little known fact is that islam is the
second largest religion percentile in
many countries in the u.s. is the second
largest religion the UK is the second
knowledge religion with four percent in
canada is the second largest religion
friends the second largest religion
germany the second largest religion and
it is continuing to grow by a percentile
of two hundred thirty-five percent i
would not say that is growing but islam
is exploding around the world by God's
leaf now as I said before Islam is the
world's fastest-growing religion every
fourth person in the world is Muslim now
if we take into account that also every
fourth person in the world is Christian
so if every fourth person in the world
is Christian and every fourth person in
the world is Muslim this means that half
the world is either Christian or Muslim
many people know about it Christianity
why does no one know about its name i'm
here today god willing to try can't give
you some information about that
one-third of the countries of the world
one-third of the countries of the world
58 out of 189 have over a fifty percent
population of muslims one-third of the
countries of the world fifty percent
muslim population today there are over
10 million muslims in the USA and there
are over 4,000 mosques in the US and
canada alone 4,000 mosques within the US
and canada loan and their new mosque
being built all the time and in the year
2015 2016 as i stated before muslims in
the world will be a majority God willing
we will become a majority into the world
so I'm asking you why don't you find out
about the religion of Islam now for
yourself before this become a part of
this growing and exploding way of life
that is one of the most beautiful ways
of life God has ever revealed for
mankind
on the faces earth from the beginning of
time to the end of time which we will
discuss in detail God willing now some
of the common views that are held
between Christianity Judaism and Islam
using text from the Bible these texts
from the Bible can also be correlated
with texts from the Quran as we will see
God willing monotheism which is
something that is professed by Jews
Christians Muslims but we're going to
get into it a little more in detail in
the totem or in the Old Testament God
says over and over again uses these same
wordings but i'm going to use Isaiah 41
verse 6 I am the first and I am the last
and besides me there is no other God I
am the first at the beginning I am the
end and besides me there is no other God
I am the only God using the New
Testament mark chapter 12 verse 29 the
Bible said the Lord our God is one Lord
this is coming from the mouth of Jesus
Christ Himself the Lord our God is one
and in the Quran we have the exact same
phrase he is God the one and only which
in Arabic is cool what lava had that say
he is God the one the only we're not
saying anything different we are saying
the same things that have always been
said from the old testament to the new
testament to the quran the message has
not changed only people have changed the
message God's message as one God does
not change therefore his message could
not change his religion could not change
his ways of life they given has given to
humanity could not change they must be
the same and as we see here monotheism
is a underlying fact that has been from
the old testament to the new testament
to the quran we are not saying anything
different prophets muslims believe and
accept all the prophets mentioned in the
Torah the Bible and the Quran we accept
them we accept all of the profits
without taking or adding any of them
also with the miraculous birth of Jesus
besides Christianity Islam is the only
religion on earth that receps the
miraculous birth
we wanted the only religious that that
verify and using our books to verify
that Jesus was born of a virgin mary
this is something even the Jews
themselves they deny but we as Muslims
attest to this and defend not only Jesus
but his mother Mary peace be upon them
on this issue jesus is mentioned 25
times in the quran 25 times he is
mentioned by name in the quran the
highest honor of women in islam the
highest woman in islam that title is
given only to one woman and that is Mary
the mother of Jesus and it is given to
her in verse and chapter 19 of the Quran
which is actually entitled after her it
is surah Maryam or surah Mary or chapter
Mary of the Holy Quran there is a whole
chapter in the Quran devoted just to the
mother of Jesus Christ Mary and she is
given the highest status that can be
given to him and she's known as the
highest woman in the world in history
was given to the status of Mary the
mother of Jesus by aslam greetings all
the time you hear you hear Muslims
they'll say to each other when they
greet each other assalamu alaikum which
means peace be unto you or peace be with
you or may you have peace this is
nothing new this is not something we
invented this is not something that
Muhammad peace be upon him invented all
the prophets had this same greeting that
they used peace be with you and I'm
going to give you some Evans's God
willing as-salam-o-alaikum is in many
times when Jesus would greet the people
he would say to them peace be unto you
there's many evidences over and over
again in the New Testament when Jesus
would greet someone he would greet them
peace be unto you peace be unto you
peace be unto you this was the same that
he always used this was a statement that
was used by all the prophecies only
meant may I you have peace now another
topic taking off of shoes which is
something a Muslim does not only in the
mosque he goes here he takes off his
shoes because it is a sacred place but
even in his home in his home where he
prays he takes off the shoes why does he
take off his shoes God ordered Moses to
take off his shoes and eggs
is three and five when he saw the
burning bush the first command God gave
him ones take off your shoes because you
were standing on sacred ground put off
shoes from your feet again we see in
Joshua 5 and 15 Muslims take off the
shoes whenever they entered the mosque
or ever whenever they enter into their
homes whenever they enter into a place
where they are going to worship God they
take off their shoes purification before
prayer which in Islam is known as wudu
or ablution which we make this ritual
purification with water before we pray
is this something new let's see in
Exodus 40 30 and 31 and 32 Moses washed
his feet we see an X 21 verse 26 st.
Paul purified himself and then he went
into the temple this is something that
has been practiced by the Jews for
centuries before they enter into the
synagogue's they will wash themselves
purify themselves before they enter so
we have not invented anything new we are
just continuing the path in the example
of the prophets we were just continuing
to follow the example of all the
prophets then we're doing the same thing
we have not invented anything fasting
Muslims fast for 30 days during the
month of Ramadan for one month we fast
during the daylight hours in order to
purify ourselves before God is this
something new let's see and Matthew 12
it is said that Jesus fasted for 40 days
he fasted for 40 days this was something
he was known to do too fast he said some
things can only be come through fasting
and prayer so fasting was a tradition of
Jesus was a tradition of the prophets so
we have not invented anything new
Ramadan is nothing new Ramadan is
something that has been practiced by all
the proper taking time to purify
themselves to free themselves from the
needs of this world and order to draw
near the Sun to god this is something
that has always been practice now this
topic is one of the things that helped
bring me to a slam the issue of humbling
and how Muslims pray you see it all the
time whenever they mention Muslims you
talk about Islam they will show Muslims
in prayer most of the time going into
the prostrate
everyone one is white why do you have to
bump your head on the floor what is it
necessary I can't just talk to God why
do I need to bump and bow my head on the
floor is this something new let's see
humbling while praying by bowing heads
to the ground we see in Genesis chapter
17 verse 3 Moses bowed his head Abraham
fell on his face Jesus fell on his face
and prayed in Matthew 26 and 39 this is
nothing new this is something Abraham
Moses Jesus all the prophets did they
prostrate their face on the ground in a
semblance of supreme submission to God
the lowest point you can reach on the
earth is with your face on the ground
and in that position you are praising
God who is the most high it is the most
supreme form of worship Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said that I slave is
closest to his Lord when he is in that
position of frustration because he has
lowered himself to the lowest position
he can come to in this earth in order to
praise the supreme creator who is the
most high we are not inventing anything
new this is one thing that I saw I used
to play like this as a Christian even
though I didn't know what I was doing a
traditional Muslim prayer and when I
first encountered Muslims and saw them
pray this is one of the things that led
me to see that they are not doing
anything new this is something that I've
always read about in the Bible not
burning two statues and images not
giving serenity not giving worship not
giving adoration to any type of images
in Exodus it says thou shalt not make
any graven images this is the second
commandment number one thou shalt have
no other God before me first commitment
or no other God with me or no other God
beside me and number two you should not
worship any graven images nothing that
you create with your hands should you
give a duration or worship to Muslims do
not bow to statues images or anything
except God we do not give that which is
reserved for God we do not give any of
the worship or admiration that is
reserved to God alone to anything except
God decoration of trees
this is a big thing during Christmas
time you go you cut down the tree you
bring it in your house and you decorate
it it is forbidden in the Bible in
Jeremiah chapter 10 verses two through
five it says cursed are those who
venture into the wilderness and cut down
a tree and bring it into their homes and
decorate it with tinsel and silver this
was something that was practiced by the
paintings as coming at the winter time
everything would die everything was
dying around them all the leaves were
falling off the trees everything was
dying in nature except for this one tree
this one evergreen tree was staying
alive so they would imagine it
themselves that it had some type of
mystical power it had some semblance
towards life it had some God within it
that kept it alive so for this reason
they would cut it down and bring it into
their homes during the winter solstice
Soulstice or the shortest days of the
year which coincide with the day of
December 22nd through the 25th these
were the shortest days of the year so
they would bring this tree into the home
decorate it and give it worship and now
we and I used to do as Christian will do
the same thing we do not know what comes
from pagan worship forbidden in the
Bible Muslims do not do this everlasting
covenant God made a covenant with
Abraham and his descendants this
covenant was symbolized by circumcision
the males were circumcised at birth this
was a covenant made with God to Abraham
and his progeny as a semblance to their
surrender its to him Muslims still keep
this covenant we must it is an
obligation upon a Muslim to circumcise
their sons at birth or add what is known
as a [ __ ] or the eighth day of their
their life where they are given the
circumcision and given their name this
is not something practicing Christianity
why it's in the Bible why is it not
practiced you have to ask yourself that
question but we as Muslims are
continuing in the tradition of the
prophets we are not inventing anything
new we were just following that which
has always been there Abraham's son
Ishmael the name for Ishmael was given
to Abraham son by God himself in Genesis
16 and 11 so those who tried to say and
try to disprove the the prophethood of
Muhammad peace be upon him by saying
that Ishmael was an ill
son from Abraham because it was of his
second wife then asked them let
themselves ask them you asked them why
did God name Ishmael himself if he was
not legitimate if he was not given the
Covenant along with Isaac and he was
given the Covenant that Isaac would have
a great kingship and Ishmael would
become a great nation if this covenant
was made with both and god named Ishmael
himself that how could he be
illegitimate I'm here to say that the
Bible disproves that Muslims respect
Ishmael like Isaac as a son of Abraham
wine-drinking prohibited this is
something that is throughout the entire
Bible throughout the entire Bible in the
Old Testament is forbidden and in the
New Testament is forbidden and Luke one
in 115 drink me the wine nor strong
drink drink neither wine nor strong
drink Muslims do not drink wine or
alcohol ever it is forbidden in Islam
this is nothing new this is nothing new
it is something that Islam has always
always preached and it's something that
God is always taught that a wine or
strong drink or forbidden they bring
about eels in society and we know this
even with this country know that it
bring ills of society they even
prohibited it back in the 1920s alcohol
was prohibited in this country but
people were bringing it in so illegally
they decided what we need to get in on
this money so they made it legal so they
can brush profit off with an tax it but
they know the ills of it it has been
forbidden by God all throughout time
pork pork is forbidden in the Bible God
ordered Moses and the swine is unclean
to you in Leviticus 11 7 so why if Jesus
was a follower of Moses if he came to
redefine the law of Moses he never
commanded a 20 port that he thought no
hidden anymore did he command anyone to
eat pork no did he give anyone
permission to eat the pork no so why do
you eat it why is it even jesus never
ate pork in his life and muslims are
forbidden to eat pork or have any
dealings with pork Ussery interest
interest is
in the Bible in the Bible in Leviticus
one of the commandments given to Moses
was take down no Ussery and then in
Psalms 15 and 5 it says he has put not
out his money to Ussery Ussery or
interest scandal in and and and scheming
the people out of their wealth through
deception through high interest rate
through taking their money loading the
money and taking back three and four
amount the time times the amount has
been forbidden in the Bible and it is
one of the ills that keep society in the
position where the rich stay rich the
poor stay poor it makes a huge
separation in classes and this is
forbidden by God in the Bible and
actually in the Islam there's an
establishment cause like at where
everyone is supposed to give away they
have to give away a certain percentage
of their money to the poor in order to
put everyone in the equal standing so
this is why it was forbidden in the
Bible and this is why Muslims still
carry on this tradition and we do not
allow user II we do not allow interest
when I take it nor do we give interest
disapproval of homosexuality we know for
sure the story of Sodom and Gomorrah in
the Bible where it says the Lord rained
upon Sodom and Gomorrah he overthrew
those cities in Genesis he overthrew in
destroyed city completely just for the
practice of homosexuality now it is
something that is rampant in something
in the world accepted you even have
churches that are homosexual and lesbian
churches you have homosexual priests
homosexual pastors ask yourself what why
is this why can this be allowed this is
something that God has always said and
this is something that is forbidden in
Islam Islam forbids homosexuality we
were just continuing on in the tradition
of the prophets in the traditions of
what God has always said no original sin
here's the big one the Sun shall not
bear the iniquities of the father is
equal 18 and 20 that verse goes on to
say that no man can bear the sins or the
burdens of another Muslims believe that
sin cannot be transferred or inherited
from person to person we cannot inherit
the sins of our fathers our fathers
could not inherit the sins of their
fathers nor can we inherit the sins of
Adam God forgave Adam
just as he can forgive us we are born
pure without sin this is something that
has been taught throughout the Bible
there was no mention of original sin
throughout the whole entire Bible so if
you take this away if you take this
concept of the original sin away then
you take away the need for Jesus Christ
peace be upon him to sacrifice himself
on a cross for the forgiveness of our
sins because it is only God who can
forgive sins no one can take on everyone
else's sins and be punished for them
this would be injustice and not only
what God not give injustice to a single
individual but surely he would not do
injustice to one of his prophets
accountability every man shall receive
his own reward to his own label this is
in first Corinthians 3 and 8 every man
is accountable for his own action before
God what he does what he says how he
acts he will be accountable for God
himself Muslims believe that every
person is accountable for his or her
deeds and they will be rewarded or
punished accordingly to them this is the
Islamic belief Muslims are observing and
maintaining not only are we observing we
are maintaining and preserving the
instructions that are given in the Torah
in the New Testament in the Bible we
preserve them and continue to practice
them up into this day now let's get into
the question about Muhammad peace be
upon him Muhammad how much do you know
about Muhammad is he in the Bible can
the Bible verify his message let's find
out he is the last messenger of god to
the day of judgment and his pop the hood
is for the entire world he was the only
prophet sent to the entire world even
Jesus himself was only sent to the Jews
by his own mouth when he was asked to
preach into a Gentile he said why why I
cast my pearls into swine he was only
sent to the Jews this was his only
mission but Muhammad peace be upon him
was sent to all the world he is God's
messenger he is not God in any way there
for Muslims do not worship Him we do not
prefer to be referred to and we do not
like to be called muhammadans or or we
do not like Islam to be referred to as
Muhammad ism
which is so what is put in some text
some college text some dictionaries some
encyclopedias you will see Islam
referred to Muhammad ISM or muhammadans
we're left muhammadans we're not
worshipers of Muhammad where worshippers
of the one true God who was talked to us
how to worship Him by Mohammed who was
only a man and a Messenger of God he
received the first message from God
through the angel Gabriel at the age of
40 he spent ten years in Mecca and 13
years of Medina to preach aslam and he
died as a regular human being at the age
of 63 years old during these 23 years
the Quran was revealed piece by piece
according to the time and necessity for
Humanity Muhammad was an ordinary person
with a family and a children he was the
leader of a nation and a teacher now
let's get into some of the prophecies is
he in the Bible yes he's in the Bible
where is he in the Bible I've never read
that Muhammad is in the Bible i'm going
to show you God willing open your heart
open your mind you will see God bless
Abraham mohamed came from the progeny of
Abraham through Ishmael promised by God
where he promised by God that I will put
one who will raise up I will raise up
one from your brethren from your nation
from your brethren who I will put my
words into his mouth and he will speak
that which I revealed to him he will not
say anything of his own accord but only
that which I revealed to him will he
speak and we know that this is how the
Quran was revealed the Quran was
revealed by God directly to Muhammad in
his mouth and he quoted it for the
people it was never any of his own words
mixed in it was God revealed directly to
him through him and also in this verse
it says he will be like you people refer
this verse to Jesus but if I had the
time I would break down to you that this
could not meet Jesus Jesus and Muhammad
and Jesus having almost no similarities
other than they bein prophets of God to
the Jews but as far as them being as
Moses being the leader of a nation and
some having a family having wise having
children things like this cannot be
Jesus because he said he will be like
you the only person who this can refer
to from the Brethren who was given the
word in his mouth is Muhammad who had
these things he was the leader of a
nation he did have a family he did why
is he did have children God did reveal
things in his mouth he spoke them
directly to the people this verse was
revealing directly to him also in
Genesis it says the rejected stone Jesus
spoke of the kingdom of God being taken
away and given to the rejected stone who
is referred to the rejected the stone is
referred to in Genesis 21 13 through 18
the rejected stone is known as the
nation of Ishmael this is the rejected
stone because know the healer wouldn't
be rejected his nation will be rejected
by those who say that he is not
legitimate so this rejected stone is the
nation of Ishmael or the nation of
Muhammad peace be upon him the first
revelation this is one of the most
interesting prophecies in the Bible
above Muhammad read this he said I am
NOT learned replied this is an Isaiah
2912 the story goes that the book was
revealed unto one saying read your book
I pray the person replied saying I
cannot read historical facts angel
Gabriel delivered the first revelation
of Quran in this first revelation of the
Quran was eager abyss Meribah Colletti
Halak read in the name of your lord who
created man and then Muhammad replied to
him I am NOT learned I cannot read he
replied in Arabic and the makati which
means I am NOT learned which are the
exact words of the Bible then it is also
said which is a very interesting point
in the Bible at the end of this verse
the next verse down it says the verse
was revealed first 21 saying read your
book I pray he said I cannot for it is
sealed the first person who was given
the book said I cannot open it because
it is sealed now and then it was given
to the next one he said I can already
find not learned we already stated that
how this is a prophecy directly related
to her Muhammad now this book which is
sealed is referred to again in
Revelation in Revelation it says that
the book was brought had seven seals and
it was said only the chosen one of God
can open it this book had seven seals
and only the chosen one can open it open
the first
page of the Quran first chapter the
title of this chapter is fatty hi 30 hi
means that which opens something that
which releases or open something count
how many verses in surah fatiha 77 vs is
this a coincidence you asked you
yourself the audience have to ask that
for yourself to me it's too big of a
coincidence the book was delivered to
one saying and it was delivered to Jesus
I mean no excuse me it was delivered to
John the Baptist and asked him to open
he said I can't open it for a sealed in
Revelation this was a direct prophecy
there was prophesied in Isaiah it was
the lip DM saying read it he said I
can't for a sealed with seven seals and
only the chosen one of God can open it
linen was delivered to Muhammad say it
read and he said I can't because I can't
read that was his direct answer this is
a direct prophecy in the Bible about
Muhammad can I prefer to anyone else
profit from Arabia Arabia the Prince of
cadbury is known in Ezekiel 27 and 21
historical fact many converts my grid to
Medina Muhammad migrated in 622 the next
year a thousand meccans marched against
Muslims all the princess of Kendall this
is kendall was known as the area of
mecha mecha was known also as Kevin a
prophet like Moses God said to Moses I
will raise up a prophet like unto thee
and I will put my words in his mouth and
you should speak them all we just
referred to this how this cannot refer
to Jesus but Muhammad peace be upon him
historical fact angel Gabriel used to
bring these revelations from guide to
Muhammad and he put these words in his
mouth he does not speak of his own
desire what says the Quran the Quran
chapter 53 53 3 & 4 says he does not
speak of his own desire he only says
that which is revealed to him which is
exactly the same wording used in the
Bible and this prophecy in Deuteronomy
18 and 18 prophet gave laws he will not
fall or be discouraged till he
establishes justice on the earth mohamed
came with a complete code of laws in
spite of persecution and physical
assaults he was never discouraged no
Express despair in his mission profit
with ten thousand saints this is a very
clear prophecy he came with ten thousand
saints and
his right hand when a fiery long this is
in Deuteronomy 33 verse 2 historical
fact Muhammad returned to Mecca after he
was banished from Mecca to Medina when
he came back to overtake Mecca he came
back with 10,000 Muslims he established
the rule of law there in Mecca which is
known as Sherea Sherea means a
prescribed law or a fiery law he came
with 10,000 Saints to Mecca and
established the law or the Sharia over
Mecca until Shiloh comes Jacob told his
children until silo comes silo is in
Genesis 49 verse 10 and silo means peace
in Hebrew so it is he Jacob told his
children until peace comes until the
peace comes which we know Islam is d
peace pilgrimage a back of the Bekaa
Valley they go through the valley of
baka there it has a place of Springs and
early rain also covers it with pools
psalm 84 5 through 6 Mecca is referred
to in the Quran as becca and soda three
I had 96 is referred to as becca in the
Quran back in the Bible the famous ZEM
ZEM spring is located near the will of
ZEM ZEM that has been there since the
time of Abraham the most famous spring
in the world is there in Mecca prophecy
from the Bible also Mecca gets flooded
before they built the the dams and then
in the times of Olmec used to always get
flooded in the springtime when the rains
come me but always flood this is a
direct prophecy in the Bible clear up
and cut clear and simple and to the
point cannot be put and and and
explained away it any other way I
challenge you explain it away in another
way is very clear very simple revealed
little by little he teaches knowledge
line upon line here a little there a
little Isaiah 28 9 and 11 we know the
Quran was revealed piece by piece here a
little there a little depending on the
and the time this is directly in the
Bible posted by name in the Hebrew text
Muhammad was quoted by name Chico mentor
hiking vet aluminum this is in the
Hebrew text the name muhammad in and it
is translated his language is most sweet
and he is Muhammad but it is translated
in english as the praised one or the one
full of praise which we know Muhammad
means he who is praised on this earth
directly in the Hebrew text Muhammad and
there is a tradition or a saying of
Muhammad a story when some Jews came to
him and asked him questions and
eventually they accepted Islam one of
the jews said to him that i have read
your name in the door i have seen your
name for the past 25 years and have
tried to erase it and every day it would
be there back when i wake up in the
morning it would be back he was
redirected referring to this verse in
the Old Testament prophet come to pass
when a prophet speaks if his word does
not come to pass or come true the word
which the Lord has not spoken we know
God informed hundred of many different
prophecies he directly prophesized the
fall of the Romans that the Romans will
be defeated with the feed the Persians
this is in the quran the chapter Romans
and the Quran was revealed during that
time in support of the Christians the
Romans won the battle in 627 so a
prophet has to be verified the things he
says has to be verified that they do
come to pass we know the many prophecies
a prank muhammad have come to pass go
read his prophecies for yourself see if
they have not come to pass see if one is
a line and I surely assure you that you
will not find one Muhammad predicted
many future events all these things
happen for sure there are some I'm going
to mention very quick references about
Muhammad also in Hindu scriptures and
some of the Hindu scriptures you read
that his name will be Muhammad Muhammad
Aaron o ye the pride of mankind the
dweller of Arabia also it says Ahmed
acquired religious law from his Lord the
law of religion is full of wisdom he is
not only in the Bible but other
religious texts Muhammad is directly
directly referred to we're not saying
anything there's not been said
all of the nations all of the people
brought to them by their prophet
muhammad is expressly stated many many
times his name will be Muhammad Jesus
foretold Muhammad he should give you
another comforter this word comforter is
known as a parcel eight or a comforter
Muhammad is given the title in the Quran
by God himself as rock metal illa ala
mean meaning a mercy or a comfort to the
world he was given by God as a comfort
to this world and he was that comforted
with Jesus himself spoke about jesus
said I have many things to say unto you
but you cannot bear them now but he when
he comes the Spirit of Truth the spirit
of truth comes he will show you things
to come John 16 14 the message of Jesus
was incomplete it was incomplete if he
was the last prophet then why did he say
I have many things to say to you but I
can't tell you my mess is incomplete but
another one is going to come and
complete my mission and another of
profit was needed and this prophet was
Muhammad who came peace be upon him 600
in 10 years after the death of Jesus or
after the so-called death but as we as
Muslims know that he did not die he was
removed from this world by God during
that time 600 years later was Muhammad
peace be upon him came to this world
Gospel of Barnabas which we would have
to get into into some detail about the
validity gospel Barnabas it says
muhammad is his lesson name in the
Gospel of Barnabas which we know
Barnabas was a verified disciple of
Jesus Christ he had a gospel just like
Matthew Mark Luke and John why was it
not added to the Bible you go read it
for yourself and ask yourself that same
question all holy books lead to believe
in Muhammad in the Quran they all lead
to the same thing they are all leading
in the same direction they will all lead
you to his name if you look at them with
the open mind and an open heart
the Quran the Quran is the collection of
all revealed messages from God to
Muhammad it is memorized by millions of
people even today original copies of
this Quran still exist one in at
eschaton when it was becca stan and the
other in Istanbul Turkey Sir William you
or who is a well-known oil orient to
this writer wrote there is probably in
the world no other book which has
remained 14th centuries with so pure
text nor the book that has remained with
such a few texts that is uncorrupted
unadulterated 1400 centuries that it is
as bin census revealed dr maurice
bhosale a french christian physician
compared scientific facts of the bible
in the quran he found many scientific
verses in the quran each of them is
correct and he wrote he wrote a
christian physician scientists wrote I
cannot find a single error in the Quran
this guy eventually became Muslim he
wrote a book called the the the Quranic
modern science by Maurice Messiah when
he went through these prophecies and the
scientific facts in the Quran that were
not known to anyone until the present
day they were known by Muhammad peace be
upon him they were revealed in the Quran
the Quran has many scientific facts
unknown to man 1400 years ago they were
revealed in the Quran each of them has
proven to be scientifically true for
instance the big bang theory of creation
of the universe the planets and other
patterns of the cosmos the conception
and stages of the embryological growth
the development of the human these
things revealed in the Bible I mean
revealed in the Quran excuse me revealed
in the Quran reference to fingerprints
how everyone has a unique fingerprint
this is not known into the 19th century
revealing the Quran 1400 years ago how
is it possible for an unlettered person
Muhammad could not read or write he had
no formal educational training how is it
that he an ordinary human being
uneducated knew these scientific
mysteries 1400 years ago when no man on
the earth had knowledge of them you
asked yourself that ask yourself if he
is not from God how did he know these
things
the Gospel of Barnabas as i said i'm
going to spend a brief amount of time on
it the Gospel of Barnabas Barnabas was a
very close companion of Jesus the Bible
referred to him as an apostle in acts 14
and 14 he wasn't a puzzle of Jesus a
good man full of the Holy Spirit and a
faith in acts 11 says he was a good man
full of the holy spirit of faith in 325
AD the followers of st. Paul gain
control at the council of nicea and made
the following changes it canonized the
for Greek Gospels that are read today it
said that these only these four Gospels
Matthew Mark Luke and John these are the
only ones that we can use you're not
going to use any of the other all of the
rest of them were ordered to be
destroyed and good in gospel of barnabas
they said we're going to use these for
because they agree with what we teach
they agree with what we believe
everything else we're going to throw it
away even Luke himself in his own
Testament says that the reason why I
wrote this Testament the way I wrote it
is because it's what seemed good to me
it's what seemed like would fit with the
people with me not because I knew it
would be true but because I knew it
would fit with the people and these are
the ones that the followers of st. Paul
at this council decided they were going
to keep the rest they didn't wait this
why ask yourself the only gospel written
in Aramaic there was one gospel written
in Aramaic which they did discover
pieces of it when they revealed the Dead
Sea Scrolls then were just sayings of
Jesus they had nothing to do with the
the salvation of mankind through the
death of Christ they were only his
sayings the 11 the one that was revealed
his language was also destroyed now
since I have clearly showed that Islam
can be found in the Bible what Muslims
teach can be found in the Bible we are
not saying anything new we have not
revealed Muhammad was not given anything
new piece of me upon him he was given
that which was given to Adam which was
given to Moses which was given to Noah
which was given to Abraham which was
given to Jesus peace be upon them all is
exactly the same so now if what we have
is exactly the same if it's lamb is
exactly the same what is this then what
is this then if it's the same thing then
practice by all the prophets then what
is it if it's not what I'm practicing
personally then what is it
and this we must spend some time on
since I've showed you how the
verification can be proven in the Bible
let's find a little bit about what is
this Islam Islam has two meanings a
linguistic meaning the linguistic
meaning of Islam is surrendered purity
and peace basically that I gain peace
through continual submission to the will
of God alone it also has an Islamic
meaning a meaning by given to it by
Islam if a person fully surrenders
himself to Almighty God alone worshiping
him purely he would live in peace and
harmony in this life and in the life
Hereafter this was the message of Jesus
to surrender yourself the greatest
commandment surrender yourself to Lord
your God with all your might with all
your heart with all your strength and
then love your neighbor as you love
yourself these are the greatest
Commandments we're not saying anything
new we're quoting and repeating Muhammad
is a message peace be upon him that was
given to all the prophets Muslim means a
person who submits himself to the will
of god that is it a Muslim is someone
who submits his entire self to the will
of God Islam is also based upon six
beliefs six beliefs five actions or five
pillars or five actions six inward
beliefs that are proven by five out of
actions these six beliefs are number one
belief belief in the Almighty God alone
that he is one he has no partners he
does not show you the miniature but
anyone as the Bible says that I am the
lord your god and I am a jealous God
says God in Deuteronomy I am a jealous
God I do not like for you to share my
Dominion ship with anyone in the Bible
Islam says the same thing Muhammad peace
be upon him taught the same thing second
is that we believe in the Angels we
believe in the angels of God and we
believe in all of them also we believe
in all the books we believe in all the
books of God we believe in the Torah we
believe in the Bible in their original
form which we also believe that they are
not now in their original form they have
been corrupted by mankind's hands and do
not contain the original message pieces
are still there as I just showed you we
believe in all the messengers all the
profits from adam to the time of
Muhammad peace be upon him we believe in
all the messengers
we believe in the Day of Resurrection
that everyone will have to stand before
God on the day of judgment and give a
count for what he's done and he will be
rewarded or punished accordingly and we
also believe in the divine destiny we
also believe every human being is born
pre-formatted to submit to God this is
something that is imprinted into our
soul our soul created by God out of
nothing has within it that small
impression that we know who is God we
have that yearning and our soul that
always will lead us towards God whether
we like it or not for that reason we
cannot go to God on the judgment and say
we did not know because for sure he's
gonna say we know you know because I
created your soul I created your soul
and I know it no human beings have a
freewheel we're able to choose between
right and wrong this is according to
Islam there is no compulsion in religion
I cannot force you to become Muslim we
cannot force its name on anyone Islam
was not spread by the sword because then
it would be illegal to do so Islam was
spread by the character and the
teachings of Muhammad peace be upon him
and the early Muslims people are born
without inherited sin we do not inherit
the signified them we were responsible
as i showed you for our own actions we
cannot bear the sins on the burdens of
another there are no supremacy all
people stand as equals before God in the
relation to him they're all equal we all
will be judged according to the same
thing we are judged only we are only
elevated in levels according to piety
not according to race tree Creed tribe
language nothing just by our piety
before God that's how we are raised in
elevating in Louisville belief in Allah
we must believe that there is no deity
of worship except Allah worship is for
Allah or God alone a lot is the proper
name for God aired Christian and Jews
called the deity Allah as well 15 times
the word Allah is in the Christian Bible
on the first page as we will see Allah
has many attributes and names which
describe him we see here in the Bible we
see we see the word the first page of
the Bible we see Allah here we see a la
here we see a la here we see a lion this
this feel me haha december why people
aren't on the first day Allah created
the heavens and the earth the first of
the page of the Old Testament a la 15
times on this page we're not doing
anything new we're not saying anything
new this is just a name that is given a
title and respect as a proper name for
God we believe Allah is unique he has no
partners you cannot imagine him in your
head you cannot picture him or a wall
you cannot picture him in your mind he
alone is the creator of everything that
exists no one helped him create anything
he did it alone without help he does not
have any progeny he is not born from
anyone nor can anything be born from him
and there is nothing quite like him he
is neither male nor female he has no
gender he has no race he has no Creed
his angels we believe that they are
created from light they do not have a
freewheel they cannot disobey God they
carry specific tasks such as carrying
messages like the angel Gabriel they
protect human beings and they record our
deeds we each have an angel to angels
when they record our good deeds one that
record our bad deeds everything we do
say or think is being recorded by these
angels this is the Islamic belief that
is the same belief that has been passed
on through the ages his books we believe
in all of them the scrolls of Abraham
the Torah the the Psalms of David which
is known as as the bore the gospel which
is the the New Testament the gospel of
Jesus Christ in his original form LeBron
Gabriel carried them to the messengers
in their original form they were all one
hundred percent correct the only one
that exists now in its original form is
Quran revealed in this original language
arabic it's not been changed and 1400
years has not been changed it is the
only one that can still be said to be a
validity source of how I should live my
life in front of God what is the Quran
the Quran is the last revelation to
humankind it is the principal source of
every Muslims faith in practice it deals
with all subjects that concerning human
beings including wisdom doctrines
worship and law its basic themes are
that the relationship between god and
his creatures and between people and one
another the quran provides guidelines
for a just society proper human can
and equitable economic principles all of
this in the Quran has to live your life
in every aspect is in the Quran and was
exemplified by the life example of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him his
messengers we believe that there was one
message for all the messengers they
worshipped God alone and do not
associate part of them this was a single
unifying message of all the prophets
worship God alone and do not associate
partner with him all messages were the
best human beings they did not commit
major sins as the Bible attributes to
the prophets and being drunkards and
murderers and thieves and scandalmongers
these are not our profits this is not
how the prophets were this is what hit
men have put their hands to to lower the
profits to their level so they could
justify their own actions they brought
the profits down because they could not
reach their level so they would bring
them down the people who had the right
to change these things so that they
could justify their actions how I can be
any better than this person Loki was a
notary it was a killer how do you expect
more from me he was a prophet I'm a
human being this was the reason for this
justification none of them are divine
they're all normal human beings chosen
by God to deliver the message Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was a messenger
just like all of the other messengers
puff muhammad peace be upon him was not
the founder of his land he did not found
this land Prophet Muhammad is the last
messenger of allah islam was founded by
god himself his traditions which are
known as his Sunnah his ways are
considered the second source of islamic
knowledge and legislation after the
crime before becoming a profit the Arabs
used to call him the trustworthy and the
truthful Alamy he was known as the
trustworthy in the truthful his message
was well accepted may everyone until he
started trying to call the people to the
worship of one God from paganism then he
became a liar but he was always known as
a truthful person for Muslims he's the
most beloved person and the example to
be followed we follow Muhammad who was a
follower of all of the prophets Jesus
was a follower of all the prophets they
all followed the same way which was
revealed
by God we are following the last prophet
mohammed because his example his message
is still delivered to us in a clear way
that has not been changed here is a
sample of some of his traditions so you
can see what the teachings of Muhammad
where himself were they were they harsh
traditionally push people to a slam no
he said none of you truly believes until
he wishes for his brother when he wishes
for himself he eats his feel while his
neighbor goes without food he is not a
believer powerful is not the one who
knocks the other one down but indeed the
powerful one is who can control himself
when he's angry God does not judge you
according to your bodies or appearance
but he scanned your heart and looks at
your deeds the most harmful container I
person may feel is his stomach a few
bites are enough for him or else
one-third for his food one-third for his
drink and one-third for his breath these
are some examples of the wisdom of
Prophet Muhammad that was given to him
by God alone he was not a learned men
all of his knowledge everything he
learned and the wisdom behind him not
being learned was that everything he
learned was directly from God alone
could not be attributed to anyone else
because his only source was God let's
see what other people said about
Muhammad peace be upon him lamartine a
famous historian a famous french
historian in turkey you spoke French
from Turkey he said in his book if
greatness of purpose smallness of means
and outstanding results are the three
criteria of human genius who could dare
compare any great men in modern history
with Muhammad peace be upon him no one
dared to compare with him in the way
that his example was in the way his
purpose was delivered and revealed
Bernard Shaw a very well known name in
Western journalism in western arm book
writing he wrote in a book called the
genuine Islam he was not Muslim by the
way I believe that if a man like him
were to assume the leadership of the
modern world he was succeed in solving
its problems in a way that would bring
to this world much needed peace and
happiness he also said that if you were
in lead of the world today where he to
put be put in charge of the world today
he would solve the world's problems
while having an after
cup of tea this is how simple it would
be for him because why because his
knowledge was revealed directly by God
he would be able to solve the world's
problems with just his answers and we
know that the solution to the world's
problems today is nothing else other
than Islam Islam will read that bring
the world the peace that it is searching
for but people know this this is the
reason why Islam has been given a bad
face because we want to avoid this from
people we don't want the people to know
this little m is what is going to bring
you peace not terror we are the ones who
bring peace to the world Muhammad was a
mercy into mankind not something to be
afraid of also michael Hart a famous
Christian he wrote in his book ranking
the hundred most influential people in
history he wrote my choice and he chose
as a Christian Muhammad as number one he
chose Muhammad is number one he said my
choice of Muhammad to lead the list of
the world's most influential persons may
surprise some readers and may be
questioned by others but he was the only
man in history who was supremely
successful on both the religious and
secular levels it is this unparalleled
combination of secular and religious
influence which I feel entitled Muhammad
to be considered the most influential
single figure in human history of humble
origin Muhammad founded and populated
one of the world's greatest religions
and he became an immensely effective
political leader today 13th centuries
after his death his influence is still
powerful and persuasive upon the people
the fifth pillar we had our the fifth
belief is in the day of judgment we
believe that we will be resurrected
after our death we also believe that our
book of these will be read in front of
the people everything we done will be
exposed other that which God has
concealed through his forgiveness we
will be accountable for everything that
we have done we will receive a fair
judgment in front of God we will be
judged equitably in with justice in
front of God and then according to what
do we have done we will be either given
eternal paradise or will be sent to hell
fire six divine destiny
this means in Arabic is known as puddle
cuz it means that nothing happens
without the knowledge of God he sits
outside of time he does not see things
as we see them through a progression of
time he is the creator of time and he
sits outside of it he sees the beginning
of time and the end of time all at the
same time all of that is encompassed by
his knowledge so he already knows what
you're going to do it's not as he's
gonna make it you do it he does not make
you do anything you do with your own
free will be he already knows he already
knows what choice you make he already
knows what choice you will not make God
knows what happened what is going to
happen and what will happen he knows the
fourth the fourth means that he knows
what will not happen and if it happened
how it could happen he knows what
choices you will make which you will not
make and what choice is that if you were
to make them how you would make them and
how they would be an act and this is how
encompassing his knowledge is he knows
what will happen what is happening what
will happen and he knows what would not
happen and if it did happen he knows how
it would happen this is how great the
knowledge of God is now the five beads
or the five pillars number one is the
inseparable testimony and we're bringing
this thing to a close God willing the
inseparable testimony is Layla hi allah
mohammed ur rasoolallah there is no
deity but Allah there is no god but God
the one true God Allah alone and
Muhammad is His Messenger this is the
number one deed of Islam that after you
believe it in your heart you must
promise it profess it with your mouth in
order to be saved which this is in the
Bible that the in the hearts you believe
in the mouth is confessed under
salvation this is a book of Romans
chapter 10 same thing that Islam is
saying establishing the prayer as the
second need of the second clervius name
establishing regular prayer for the
remembrance of God this was something
that was known in the Bible David used
to pray three times a day facing
Jerusalem Jesus used to pray on regular
basis Moses prayed on a regular basis
we're not doing anything new this is in
order to keep us in our members of God
in the morning afternoon mid afternoon
evening night you cannot forget about
good well god is giving us 8a a method a
system to always have him in our
remembrance so as they say pray without
ceasing
the mind to always have emitted
remembrance 3 paying the financial
obligation which is known as the cap you
pay a certain percent of your savings to
give for fasting the month of Ramadan
and 5 making the pilgrimage to Mecca
these are the five deeds of Islam these
are the five things which make someone a
Muslim when he does these five things it
was a little more detail the testimony
the in several testimony this is the key
to enter into Islam to say that there is
no DVD of worship except Allah and then
Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah
whoever says this with sincerity in his
heart is to be considered a Muslim this
is how you went to into Islam whoever
dies on this belief will enter paradise
whoever dies on this belief will enter
paradise if its sins are forgiven by God
this is the first key to performing
prayers forming the daily obligations of
Salah the five daily prayers they must
be preyed on time there are certain
times the daily prayers morning before
the sunrise afternoon mid afternoon
after the sunset evening time they can
be performed on any pure spotting earth
this was a blessing given to the the
nation of Muhammad and the Muslim speed
be upon him this was given to the
Muslims before the Jews they have to go
to temples you cannot pray anywhere you
have to pray the temple even in
Jerusalem to pray you have to go to the
Western Wall to pray you have to pray in
a certain spot but Muhammad was given
peace be upon him the blessing that the
whole world is a place for prayer for
you as long as it's a pure spot on the
earth one discretion that you must pray
towards Mecca this is the one this
question that you must pray towards
Mecca in order to give us a sense of
unity even Jesus used to pray facing
Jerusalem David prayed face in Jerusalem
the Muslims early Muslims the first
direction of prayer for Muslims was met
with Jerusalem then it was turned to
Mecca and Mecca a house the Ka'bah built
by Abraham himself this house was built
by Abraham and by his son Ishmael so we
are on it was the first house on this
earth built for the worship of the One
God we're turning ourselves to that
remembers that worshipping the one God
and a sense of unity all biblical
prophets like AB Abraham Moses Aaron and
Jesus from their faces in the prey
Islam is reviving the prophetic
traditions that people have forgotten
we're reviving these traditions we're
bringing back into existence that was
the people that forgotten three the
financial application Oh does a cat is
two-point-five percent of any cash
savings that are held over for one year
five to ten percent of agricultural
twenty percent of any extracting
resources and minerals anything that's
pulled out the ground twenty percent is
supposed to be given to the poor and the
needy the right it is the right that the
poor have upon the rich it is the right
that the poor have upon the rich to keep
them from being so poor it is what evens
out the balance of society so where did
I have so many different classes of
people we do not have the post staying
poor and the rich stay rich the poor
feeding in off the rich as well we have
the wealth of the rich being given to
the poor as the right zaka means growth
and purification of your wealth fasting
in ramadan during the month of ramadan
during the daylight hours we do not eat
drink or have any sexual activities from
dawn to sunset it has been prescribed on
other nations all nations have fasted it
is a ritual of worship which enhances
patience and perseverance through
discipline nothing Jesus fasted as I
showed you before all the prophets
fasted now and of course fifth is the
the the Hajj or the pilgrimage one must
make to Mecca if he has the opportunity
to do so he goes to Mecca he adores the
trip to meet and have a annual gathering
of Muslims to show their unity to show
their solidity to worship God and in the
first house and women worship for God
this is something that all nations make
pilgrimage to one place or another now
let's discuss it in breaking down the
last three very important issues that i
would like discuss which are
contemporary issues hijab or the
covering for women the status of women
in Islam and jihad let's look at this
picture here we have a picture here we
have three women we have Mary the mother
of Jesus in a Christian Church we have a
Christian nine and then we have a Muslim
woman do we see beliefs any any any
similarities here covered covered
covered you cannot tell the difference
between these three women we're not
doing she's not
doing anything different then this woman
is doing following the example of this
who is married the mother of Jesus peace
be upon him nothing new here this is a
verse from the Quran telling about the
reason white women cover but this verse
was not revealed just to the women it
was first given to the minute the men
also have the key gen they also have a
means of modesty and say to the
believing men that they should lower
their gaze and guard their modesty and
that is pure for them and a lot is aware
of what they do then it says and say to
the believing women that they should
lower their gaze and guard their modesty
and that they should not display their
beauty except that which is apparent
their face and hands and to draw their
veils or they have over all of their
bosoms and not to reveal their beauty
except to their husbands their fathers
their husbands fathers their sons their
husbands sons their brothers or their
brothers sons or their sisters sons all
of the relatives that are they cannot
marry they can show these things to them
but this is not for to be shown to the
world there's not something to broadcast
to the world this is something that is a
beauty that she alone owns and she only
came to display that beauty to someone
who is able to have it not just a
broadcast it to the world we we treasure
women in Islam we don't just throw them
to the world we protect them if you had
a a a huge diamond would you walk around
with it in your hand leave it on top of
your car set it outside on the street
would you do that no you wouldn't you
would want to keep it and guarded
because it is something precious this is
what we the status that Islam gives two
women that they are something precious
there is something to be protected there
is something to be cherished something
that is not just for everyone it is only
for those who are allowed to have them
in the same for men I don't walk in the
streets showing all of them exposing
everything I don't walk on the streets
exposing my my private parts of my areas
I expired I hide this I keep this only
for someone who is allowed to happen
which is my wife status of women women
in Islam right men have the right to
gain an education they have the right to
be educated they have the right to
engage in business and when they engage
in business their profits are theirs
alone we don't even as men don't have
any right to them they don't have to
give it to
husband they can keep it they have the
right to engage in professions they keep
them in line with the Islamic traditions
something does not take them out of the
Islamic way of life they have the right
to engage in public life they have the
right to keep their family name and
identity when I sister comes in to twist
our sister gets married she does not
have to take the name of her husband she
keeps her own name her own identity she
is who she is and keeps that identity
and her possessions everything she owns
is hers the her husband does not have a
right to take any of it if any society
and I want this to be very clear if any
society or individual Oh presses women
discriminates against them it is against
Islam and not because of it it is not
because of its name if a man or a
society or a nation Oh presses women
unjustly it is against Islam not because
of the teachings of Islam and it is
because of their own shortcomings please
do not associate this with this man the
last topic ahead this is the bill Jed
what is Jack you heard you had to use
many different ways you had Islamic
fundamentalist terrorism this that
yellow wood it was Jan jihad has a
linguistic meaning also just like a slim
the linguistic meaning links to strive
or struggle to struggle to do something
in Arabic if they build a huge villing
they will be said to them they made a
joke on this building jahoda coming from
the word jihad now meaning they
struggled a they struggled to make this
building it also has an Islamic meaning
number one Islamic meaning it is there
is a a non-violent struggle within
oneself for a life of peace this is the
number one meaning Islam gives to jab a
non-violent struggle within oneself by
life of virtue and also it has a meaning
to fight to establish justice which is
the supreme goal fight to establish
justice and eradicate evil on the earth
you had orders in the tradition of
Mohammed here's some of the rules and
regulations that part Muhammad peace be
upon him put down as rules for jihad you
are never to kill innocent people never
for no circumstance whatsoever can you
kill innocent people the Quran says if
you kill one innocent person it is as
I'm you slaughtered all the humanity and
if you say one innocent person is the
same as you've saved all of humanity
never injure prisoners of war do not
meet them do not capture them in them
kill them and cut their heads off this
is against this land never kill animals
never destroy crops never destroy
infrastructure is not to destroy their
whales you're not to destroy their their
means of communications as we see is not
the same rules that are used against
Muslims you're not to destroy their
infrastructures you only to fight those
who fight you you never mutilate the
bodies of the enemies dead or alive all
prisoners of war are given a fair
treatment even in the times of Muhammad
peace be upon him prisoners of war we're
told if you can teach ten Muslim
children to read you can go for you you
can go free this was the virtue of Miss
Lang women and children are protected
from harm you cannot touch women you
cannot touch children Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him during one of the
words that its name thought he saw a
dead woman laying in the road and he was
very upset about this and he questioned
the people around him why is this woman
dead then she was not involved in the
bathroom this is a gift its name always
bury the dead with respect they would
always bury the dead even if they were
non-muslim with respect put them in the
ground give them proper burial treat
them with respect note this is 1400
years these rules these regulations 1400
years before the Geneva Convention 49
years before Geneva Convention aslam had
these laws this is not something the
same thing Muslims are neither allowed
to accept slave your occupation we're
not allowed to be subjugated we're not
allowed to sit by and allow people to
put us into slavery to occupy us and
allow enter presses against our religion
this is something we do not accept we
are ordered to fight against this to try
to establish justice on the earth Islam
advocates moderation in this aspect to
take whatever means if they can be done
diplomatically do them diplomatic II you
first want to try to change it in the
most wise manner Islam a boars extremism
we do not like extremism extremism to
one side or the other we are moderate
we're in the middle what God has chosen
for us a middle nation a middle nation
Islam aboard terrorism the word Islamic
terrorists Islamic fundamentalist
Islamic extremists these words are
oxymoronic
fit together it's lame and terrorism do
not fit in the same sentence because
Islam is against terrorism terrorism is
gives his lamb the word war on terrorism
is an oxymoron you cannot fight a war on
terrorism because war itself means the
killing of innocent people the killings
of innocent people is terrorism in its
definition so war on terrorism is an
oxymoron cannot happen you cannot fight
a war on terrorism because terrorism is
warm oppression oppression is aboard by
its name we are not allowed to be the
oppressor all be oppressed Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said to help
your brother if he's an oppressor or if
he's oppressed they said we know how to
help him if he's impressed by how can we
help him if he's an oppressor he says
stop him from impressing so I finished
with this God willing you reconciled the
proofs with yourself that I had given
you reconcile them with your own hearts
and arrive at the same conclusions that
I have arrived at that the true original
message of the Bible end of Jesus Christ
Himself end of Adam Moses Noah Jesus
Muhammad is all the same that the gun
and they're all their message was that
the oneness of God in the truest sense
their message was the same that God is
one in the truest sense of the word and
then they all submitted themselves to
God as Muslims meaning one who submits
himself to rule of God inshallah God
willing through this information you
arrive at these same conclusions that I
arrived at because it is for the safety
of your soul it is for the salvation of
your own soul the only way to make it to
paradise is to accept God Allah as one
alone and accept all the prophets
including Mohammad the last one this is
our message of Islam that is in the
Bible in the Torah in the New Testament
we are not doing anything new except
reviving to the drift the traditions of
the prophets of old so may God guide you
ask for his guidance go back look with
an open heart at the evidences ask God
to guide you and God willing you arrive
at the same conclusions I have a right
that thank you for your time and I hope
that I have been of some benefit thank
you for watching the Dean show i sat on
what a come peace be unto you